it's great to welcome to the program
today Tom rosensteil who's an author
journalist researcher and media critic
and does so much interesting work in a
lot of the areas that that we frequently
talk about so I really appreciate you
talking to me today time good to be here
so I mean I think just generally to
frame our conversation one of the
conversations we often have about sort
of new media and online media are some
of the more obvious top-level pros and I
guess I hesitate to say cons but maybe
concerns about online media and of
course the pros as I see them have been
the lowering of barriers to entry to
getting involved in media and in
reporting increased diversity of voices
we can talk a little bit about whether
there's sort of equal access to all of
those but at least putatively diversity
of voices and hearing from more types of
people about what's going on in the
world but at the same time we've seen
the echo chambers develop the algorithms
that can sometimes increase political
polarization and partisanship to
questionable net benefit we've seen the
sort of conspiracy and actual fake news
purveyors to use that term in a very
narrow way not the way our president has
necessarily applied it so how would we
from an objective perspective start to
think about in in the balance in the net
what has been the influence of the
growth of online media well I mean you
know as with most phenomenon the trends
move in both directions so you know the
answer to are we better off or worse off
is yes both and so what you really need
to understand are what are the ways in
which we're different I think many of
the expectations that people had about
the digital revolution turned out to be
actually off slightly people were
worried about people of color and people
who work or not actually having access
to the Internet and that problem didn't
materialize the data is pretty clear
that almost everybody
has web access but it's through mobile
not broadband the notion that people
would be that there would be more
diverse content and that underserved
communities would have their own kind of
native journalism that hasn't
materialized to nearly the degree that
we expected that it would or that wit or
the people hope that it would in part
because you know you need to have some
kind of economic model for that and to
sustain it or people are doing it you
know as on a kind of voluntary basis
almost like community organizing
unsubsidized and that's been a problem
you know the notion that there would be
citizen media was really replaced by the
rise of social media what happens in
social is that people comment they pass
along things that other people have
produced and they comment on them so
this you know instead of citizen
journalism in many ways we have
polarized
hate speech or just a more polarized
debate you know and to some significant
degree what we and we didn't know this
wouldn't be the case is that people
online and so social spaces social media
in general is kind of a bipolar
atmosphere people are either euphoric or
they're very angry you don't post online
and say this is interesting I'm not sure
what to think about it it doesn't that
is not defined by the platform company
companies as significant engagement and
so it doesn't get shares it doesn't get
likes it's not you know the D I don't
know what this means
hmm this sort of response to that a news
organizational loves which is oh that's
interesting
I'll read another story if that ever
shows up you know that's not a meet
that's not a measurable response that
the platforms are looking for the other
the other the other Pro that I think is
significant I don't think we fully
appreciate it is our that this the tools
for storytelling and best for
understanding news and him for me
has exploded in a one book I did a book
called blur we talked about a print
story has six tools that you could use
to tell the story and those include a
headline a photograph the story itself
maybe a second story what we call a
sidebar maybe a pull quote or a graphic
your list stops at about six the tools
you have to tell and try and convey the
meaning of story digitally is an endless
list that I mean I stopped counting the
list at about a hundred of jotting down
the potential tools the challenge for
storytellers is which tool is the right
one but you know imagine the old
hardware store and now a modern Lowe's
and all the power tools all the tools
that existed a you know at a super
hardware store of the 21st century is
similar to the sort of tools we have for
storytelling the other thing I think we
did not fully appreciate is that we have
built a digital economy that is designed
around what separates us and they the
platform companies did that so that they
can target and add to you versus the per
versus your spouse versus your engineer
you know you can sit in a room and
everyone in that room would be getting
any different social flow and a
different set of advertising targeting
them well the companies that built that
economy this economy designed to
identify what makes us different from
each other did not contemplate the
political implications of political
actors using that technology to divide
people politically and that's the moment
we are in at the moment right now can
you talk a little bit about how so to
take I mean we'll just this is not a
random choice and there's a reason why
I'm picking it for sort of a case study
but when we think about a news outlet
like Fox News in the current
administration in the current form that
it has taken is Fox News's
power to sort of perpetuate and
disseminate what is in many cases
although there's a few examples which
we'll talk about
position and perspective of the
administration is that is the damage of
that or the concerning nature of that
mitigated by the existence of online
media or does it end up perpetuating a
further echo chamber by virtue of the
other online media outlets that just
follow Fox News in other words are we is
Fox News the or maybe I'll just leave it
there I mean in the context of an
administration that is as it currently
is and its relationship to Fox News is
online media a mitigator or an
exacerbate er of the problems you
described probably on balance an
exacerbate er but but for the following
reason yeah first off you know that one
thing that that's useful to know is that
the trust crisis we've had it basically
a 40% drop in truck 40 percentage point
drop in trust over the last 50 years
forty years but half of that decline
happened between 1980 and 1997 what was
going on
well we deregulated our media and we had
the cable explosion and they in the FM
dial radio dial exploded so people had
more choices and many of those new media
and that's how we wrote about talk radio
by the way in the 90s and called it new
media many of those new outlets since
they couldn't compete for audience based
on having deep repertory abend they they
competed for audience by marketing
themselves around ideological affinity
by being partisan and a talk radio in
particular marketed itself as the
antidote to the liberal media and as
they did that and as that guard
articulated more and more you saw it
reflected back in public opinion polling
and you saw political figures begin to
to echo the same language and go on
those programs and use it as a kind of
intercom so there's you know that's a
perfect example early of of partisan
media reinforcing and then building on a
political polarization it didn't create
it
it certainly work hand in glove with it
now you have a situation and fox has
existed since 1996
and really gained force during the Bush
administration but it was a subset of
the Republican Party was not the whole
Republican Party and it was pre social
media now Fox is aligned with the Trump
administration in a somewhat different
way than then George Bush's
administration was because his base and
and Fox's subset of the Republican
audience are closely aligned and he is
so responsive I mean he really draws on
Fox as a kind of as a kind of
intellectual force for him and so you
know there's there's a synergy it's
almost a kind of state TV and that's
certainly how it's been described now to
what extent does other media mitigate
that well some media some social media
is is intensifying that right if you're
part of that if you want to you or if
you're a subset of that subset you can
echo the influence of Fox so that
whatever their viewership is three
million at their peak show on a on a
pramana on a in primetime in the evening
it's really a bigger audience the
audience that is mitigating that or
arguing with it is it is an enraged
audience that is not a moderate audience
that's what you see in social you know
the the moderate voice the you know the
the subtle pushback that doesn't happen
in social and that's that's a measurable
effect you just don't push back in a
quiet way and so you know we both it's
mitigated but we're both pushed to the
edge and cable does that in general now
anyway the notion of filter bubbles
which I'm sure you've talked about on
the show which is that people are only
getting informations in places they
agree with doesn't exist for all topics
we don't have filter bubbles for sports
or weather or traffic but when it comes
to national politics the filter bubble
phenomena
that we only hear what we agree with has
set in and it's set in because of cable
in a significant way and so social is an
echo of that or a subset if you've got
really you know I mean hate groups use
social not cable so the reason I
partially picked Fox News for a
conversation is that the next question I
want to get to relates to two particular
people on Fox News Shep Smith and Chris
Wallace and they are what I sometimes
called occasional voices of reason on
Fox News and what it really comes down
to is when there are blatant lies told
by people in the Trump administration
they will mention that they are blatant
lies I mean it's a relatively low bar to
call someone a voice of reason but in
that context they sort of are and I'm
curious what you think is the sort of
net effect of their presence on Fox News
because on the on the one hand it's
really good to at least try to pierce
the filter bubble of an audience that
may never otherwise see it they may
never be getting alternative points of
view on the other hand they pierce that
bubble in a safely narrow way where they
will never question how it is that media
outlets like Fox News came to be so big
or so intertwined with an administration
for example and that's really a concern
because it's sort of safe descent what
do you think yeah so and you've touched
on I think a key issue which like all
the things we're talking about cuts both
ways if you're Fox or if you're MSNBC
and CNN you become to some degree
addicted to the audience that you've
built so Rupert Murdoch did not set out
to create Donald Trump but Donald Trump
became a popular figure on Fox and you
know you kind of ride the horse you know
that is winning the race and in in
television land in television thinking
you do not want to lose the lead in that
you build so every program is evaluated
on how it did relative
to keeping the audience that it had when
it came on the air so if you're on at 8
and you build on the audience that you
inherited at 759 that's good if you are
on at 9 and you start to lose the
audience that you inherited at 8:59
that's bad so there is a sort of
snowball effect that happens in cable
and you know while Donald while Rupert
Murdoch and Roger Ailes who built the
the Fox Empire imagined a kind of
populist network I don't think they
imagined Trump but they are stuck with
him now and when he's gone they will
have to reckon with that well that to
some degree is happening now at CNN and
MSNBC CNN it particularly interesting
because their anger and outrage and
personal antipathy with Trump you know
has built an audience in which people
say well I'm going to turn on the news
but they're really feeding their anger
about Trump um and you know it's it's
very hard to kind of remove yourself
from that so you know you've created a
monster to some degree kind of like the
movie Forbidden Planet where the monster
is our own fears at the end of the film
the interesting thing about and so that
that also shows what the limitations of
a Shep Smith or Chris Wallace aren't
always going to be they are they they
can't antagonize entirely the audience
that exists around them that they're
speaking to and yet in an odd way they
are more authoritative to that to that
audience because they they are you know
they they work within the Trump within
the Fox impre mater when they say
something's wrong it's much more
important than if the New York Times
says something's wrong they have the
authority of the network and speak to
that audience and but the notion that
Fox would argue which is we have a
section of the day that is for news and
a section of the day
his opinion programming that's
functionally doesn't work you have the
same audience the whole time you don't
have an open-minded audience on one show
and then it transforms itself into a
different kind of audience when Sean
Hannity comes up your building you're
talking to similar people all day long
but you are having Shep Smith talk to
those people and that is not an
unmeaning 'fl thing it creates
parameters around him but it conveys the
authority on him
yeah generally ghent generally the the
sense that I've had of it we've been
speaking to Tom rosensteil who's an
author journalist researcher and media
critic Tom so great having you and we'd
love to have you back again since
there's so much to talk about related to
these issues absolutely any time you
want